Did you explain that people with cancer should not take antioxidants like vitamin C,
vitamin E, etc. But they can use those same things in a very high dose. The answer to that
is yes, but the very high dose doesn't actually have to be very high. I mean, you don't have
to go to 10 grams of vitamin C for it to be oxidative, but you really have to get up to
at least three, four, five grams of vitamin C, vitamin E, it's even less than that. So normally,
let's say, you know, like the A-poppy we have on our store, taking even two or three of those
is at an oxidative dose. So it's it's it's it's you know, put it this way. If you're if you're just
getting your vitamin E from your food, it's having some antioxidant effect. And don't get me wrong.
Food that you're eating has antioxidants in it. Okay. You do need a level. It's not it's about
balance. Okay. You just want in a state of cancer, you want your balance to be tipped more towards
pro oxidative as far as the nutrition, the supplements you're taking it. Not as far as the toxins that
you're consuming, but as far as supplements. So, you know, you are getting antioxidants through I
ate some broccoli today. So that is helping your other cells. It's not like you're emptied all
antioxidants from consumption. That's any possible. But this from a supplement standpoint, you don't
want to be supporting the health of cancer cells. So I hope that helps and read read that article
too. I think that will be helpful too. I was talking about the whole body MRIs that they have
at Simon bed for $600 cash post. I don't think it's the same as pretty well. I'm not familiar with
those. Um, whole body MRIs that they have at Simon bed. I'm not familiar with what Simon bed is.
Um, and I, if they are a whole body MRI without gadolidium that give you the data that will give,
you know, that you need. It's all that's fantastic. So, um, and that's a really decent price. So,
so it's five to 10 grams of vitamin C pro oxidative. Yes, yes. Even I would say you don't even
score 10 grams. But again, it's like, oh, well, you have to take it all at once. So it's like, well,
I take five grams. I take a thousand milligram capsule every three hours throughout the day. Well,
no, then you're not getting, you're getting antioxidant effect because it's, you're getting that
absorbed at a thousand milligrams. And then you are, you know, that's, you know, it's got a half
life in your body. And it's pretty much gone before you take your next dose. So, no, you're getting
very strong antioxidant effect of vitamin C. So you need to take it all at once to get that effect.